pete i notice you have something in your
hand there it is the lawnmower 3.0 from
manscaped and uh i don't know if you
know this about me i'm not really a
beard
wearing guy i've obviously had this for
the duration
since we've been doing the podcast since
you know i guess it was
june when we pretty much got a start on
this season um
but i've only been growing this beard
because of the pandemic i thought it was
a great idea maybe i've got a chance to
grow a beard for the first time in my
life
many coveted beards yeah and many people
don't know me as a beard wearer and i
don't really know myself as a baby i've
known you for many years and you were
never a beard wearer and
i was going to say something yeah well
nobody really i mean i don't mind it
nobody really likes it i'm sure and i've
been
i've been smart enough to keep it
trimmed because i got this lawnmower 3.0
uh so all year i've been keeping it trim
but right now it looks a little bit uh
fuzzy time to go you think yeah so i was
gonna do this
here and give you a show i know you know
because you have one of these i have one
and honestly it's the best i mean i've
had products like that before
it is the best shaving product i've ever
had it's not even close
so i was gonna just trim myself up and
uh maybe not show you but show everybody
else how uh
how good i'm gonna look afterwards so
just to be clear we will fast forward
this will we not yeah nobody wants to
see this
okay great give me because it's kind of
gross
i'm ready to come back out here
[Music]
okay all right so i know this is
disgusting
yeah in retrospect uh maybe take two you
throw down
some paper towel perhaps yeah i don't
know if there's a take two now but what
do you think
no there's no question about the shaving
quality and you were and you were
throwing it around they're pretty
loosey-goosey not really seemingly
worried about cutting yourself no
and you don't need to because it's got
the patented blade where it's
no no nicks is what they say about this
uh here blade i'll tell you with
manscaped it provides the best in men's
grooming and hygiene made only from the
best products and ingredients for the
modern man and
manscaped has changed the grooming game
with their perfect package 3.0
essentials kit
now this is a package that comes with
the new and improved lawnmower 3.0
the water resistant cordless body
trimmer which you know
their advanced skin safe technology and
cutting edge ceramic blade
makes your trimming nick free so and the
kit includes an anti-chafing deodorant
as opposed to a chafing
deodorant nobody wants that
no or a chafing odor yes nobody wants an
odor
yeah it includes the anti-chafing
deodorant and a moisturizer to help you
feel and
smell your best subscribers to what we
call the perfect package 3.0 kit
get new replacement blades delivered to
the door every three months
and for a limited time you get not one
but two free gifts
so you get the shed which is a travel
bag where you can put all your
accoutrements in and you get the
patented high performance
anti-chafing manscaped boxer briefs
yes i'm wearing mine right now you
probably are you'll have to take my word
i'm gonna i'm just gonna have to take
your word for it you can get 20
off plus free shipping at manscape.com
when you use the promo code
what if that's right all one word we
still got something over here
i'll fix this in the break let's get to
the show
the sun formed first and then jupiter
formed out of the leftovers from the sun
and then everything else formed out of
the leftovers from jupiter
so in a really important sense if i want
to understand
where did the earth come from i better
start with where did jupiter come from
wow you really do clean up well right i
feel so much better so much lighter
and uh you know this is just feels right
not to be a hater on the beard
but this is the pete i know and love
thank you i hope uh everybody else loves
it too
uh how do you feel about a little game
of solar system trivia today solar
system trivia
why sweeping the nation i mean if
there's one thing i probably know a bit
about is the solar system a bit about is
the solar system
working at what if you know half of our
videos are set in space so
i could probably keep up you think you
know your way around the solar system do
you
i mean yeah enough i can i can get there
okay let's get cosmic start the insanity
where is
earth in relation or proximity to
the sun in the sort of order of planets
where is it well this is solar system
and uh actually sorry it wouldn't really
be solar system 101. i say that only
because
during the 2000s it kept getting rammed
in my head
this nbc promo thursday's
watch i think it was ctv third rock from
the sun
uh john lithgow jane curtin kristen
johnson
of course a young jgl who i think is a
great actor jay
joseph gordon-levitt for the
non-conversation we were just saying
earlier i really like that guy i think
he would be friends with us for some
reason
i would hope that he's a fan of the show
so yes uh jgl if you are listening
yeah call us jj yes we'd love to have
you on
okay question number two
what is the smallest planet
today in our solar system today well i
know where you're trying to lead me down
in that pathway but here's a little
tidbit that you don't maybe you do know
maybe you don't know
ceres a lot of people don't know ceres
it's a dwarf planet which would
technically make it the smallest planet
in the solar system
although it's not technically a planet
it's the largest body
in the main asteroid field in between
mars and jupiter yet to be upgraded to
planetary stars to be upgraded so
in that case i would say pluto except
for the fact that
this is where you were trying to suck me
out pluto was downgraded
in 2006 bad day for uh for pluto lost
planet status although there's still a
lot of people around the world who are
fighting for pluto yes
still uh the smallest planet then
becomes mercury
mercury and for bonus points i'm going
to tell you mercury
just slightly larger than our moon well
for showing off you'll be deducted
points how is that
next time just adding to the question uh
finally what is the largest planet in
our solar system i think
uh every school boy knows that's jupiter
and that is correct and of course
most people do know that jupiter is the
biggest planet
in the uni in the solar system but not
much more than that so
what if jupiter never existed
well i can tell you i do know a lot
about that normally i wouldn't know a
lot about something like that but i did
provide the voice for the what-if video
what if jupiter never existed
i can uh tell you a few things about it
but it'd probably be smarter for us to
have
a special guest that might be able to
expound upon that
like maybe an astronomer from nasa why
not
dr steve levin received his phd in
physics from berkeley in 1987.
he began his career at nasa's jet
propulsion laboratory in 1990
he's the project scientist for nasa's
juno mission
juno is a solar-powered spacecraft which
has been orbiting jupiter since july 4th
2016. for a few hours every 53 days
juno passes within a few thousand
kilometers of the giant planet
and collects a wealth of new information
about jupiter
the data collected so far has
revolutionized our understanding of
jupiter
and of giant planets in general
great to have you with us dr levin
thanks for joining us here today on what
if discussed
my pleasure sounds like it's going to be
fun well we're going to be talking
jupiter
and that's fun we'll get to the bigger
what if in a bit but
to be honest peter and i were talking
sort of uh before you came on
that yeah most people know that you know
jupiter is the biggest planet in the
solar system 11 times the size of earth
11 times the size of earth i think most
people don't know that but a good
factoid um some people might know that
it's a gas giant
i didn't know for years that it was the
fifth planet from the sun
and that were separated you know mars
and then jupiter that close to earth
but i mean basically my point is
relatively little common knowledge about
jupiter
it didn't feel like we'd been able to do
much exploration well the juno
mission that obviously you're such a big
part of has
changed the game how much have we
learned
about jupiter since juno uh
sort of left earth in 2016.
so um the phrase we like to use around
the
the project is it's a whole new jupiter
um
basically we sent juno to jupiter to
measure a bunch of things that hadn't
been measured before
to try to peek beneath the clouds right
because
even though jupiter as you said 11 times
bigger than the earth that's the radius
so it means you could fit over a
thousand earths inside it
it's the most massive planet in the
solar system
by far more than twice the mass of all
the others combined
and we've been studying it for hundreds
of years galileo looked at it with his
telescope
hundreds of years ago even though we
have all of that
mostly we didn't know what lay beneath
the clouds
we'd look at jupiter from the earth and
it's giant atmosphere and it's covered
with clouds
so we sent juno there to use
gravity to measure what the interior
looks like to measure the magnetic field
which comes from deep inside the planet
to use radio waves that can see through
the clouds
to go over the poles of jupiter for the
first time really and take great big
pictures in the north and south where
you can't see it from earth because
it's all in the same plane in the solar
system a whole bunch of
new kinds of measurements measuring
particles in jupiter's magnetic field
things like that and essentially
everything we measured
gave us a surprise we were looking for
is there a dense core down in the center
and
sure we expected something between maybe
three and
20 times the mass of the earth down in
the center but what we found looks like
maybe it's not a dense core with a sharp
boundary maybe it's sort of
fuzzy and it takes up like half the
radius of the planet
we measured the magnetic field and it
was way more complex than we expected it
to be with all these bunsen wiggles in
it and
and it doesn't look like a dipole like
the earth's field
and it's way different in the north and
the south we measured
through the clouds with our radio
receivers and we found that
the deep atmosphere doesn't get well
mixed the way you'd expect everybody
thought
you know get beneath the clouds and it's
this giant ball of gas it should be
pretty much the same
anywhere you look well that's totally
wrong so we got surprises
everything little thing we took a look
at even the pictures over the north and
south poles
it looks so different that the first
time we looked at the pictures
a lot of the people in the room were
saying are you sure that's jupiter it
just didn't look at all like jupiter
looks like
from the side and those pictures have
been shared right and people can
where can people find those pictures
just before i forget
yeah so there's this great opportunity
out there so we have a website called
mission juno
missionjuno.swri.edu
but you can get to it from nasa's
website or just google mission juno
and the junocam images that's the images
from our visible light camera
basically we just dump the raw data out
on the web and let anybody who wants to
play with it make their own pictures fix
up the colors stitch things together
however much work you want to do
and post them and we've gotten an
amazing response
uh we've there's several people out
there who are real
power users who who take that data and
turn it into these amazing pictures
beginning to end there's a lot more
people who take the intermediate steps
and use those and try stretching the
color changing the contrast or
combining them to make movies and do
some great things
people are doing science people are
doing art people are making pretty
pictures
it's really been fun yeah talk about
that planet in relation to our planet i
don't know
if everybody knows how much jupiter may
have affected earth's development
uh among other things it's protected us
from a lot of flying rocks but
uh what else right so the the flying
rocks thing is
basically uh if you imagine something
drifting into the inner solar system
when it gets near jupiter's orbit
jupiter gravitationally is likely to
perturb it and a lot more of those get
shot outward than gets shot inward so it
can protect us
but we're generally just the formation
of the whole solar system
when we look at how did planets form
which by the way is something scientists
don't really understand all the details
about
the most important models for how does
the solar system form how do we get
the planets um indicate that
jupiter came first uh not too surprising
because it's the largest it got there
first it got all the material
and then it affected the formation of
the whole rest of the solar system
so there's there's lots of ways to think
about that but the one i like the best
is if you just look at our solar system
like you were an alien or something and
don't know
what's there you'd come along you'd see
the sun and you'd say
maybe that's it that's all there is is
this star and you'd be
99 and a half percent right or something
because almost all the mass is in the
sun
and then if you looked a little bit
further and said oh wait i see that spec
that's jupiter right you'd be more than
two-thirds right if you said
that's all that's left because jupiter's
more than two-thirds of the remaining
mass
well the sun formed first and then
jupiter formed out of the leftovers from
the sun and then everything else
formed out of the leftovers from jupiter
so in a really
important sense if i want to understand
where did the earth come from
i better start with where did jupiter
come from
otherwise i'm never going to get the
picture so i guess the short answer to
what if
jupiter never existed would be earth
wouldn't have existed and i'm guessing
the rest of the solar system wouldn't
have existed
well i love that question because it's
actually
way more complicated than it sounds so
imagine i when you asked me that
question the first thing i thought of
is okay imagine jupiter just didn't
start to form
what would happen well the answer there
is probably
one of the other planets would have
gotten a whole lot bigger and sort of
become like jupiter
because if you look at the other really
big ones it's saturn and uranus and
neptune
what we think most likely happened
is as the planets formed they drifted
around
because they're eating up the material
and that makes the initial cloud of gas
and dust and that changes their momentum
and so their orbits shift around
and those other planets probably came
along
after jupiter was really big jupiter
altered their orbits dramatically
looks like it probably sent them outward
away from the sun
and they didn't have as much stuff
jupiter ate all the stuff
first before they could get there so if
jupiter wasn't there well maybe saturn
drifts in
further and saturn eats all the stuff
and looks a whole lot like jupiter does
now
of course exactly where they ended up
depends on all of that process
so if you take jupiter out of the mix
you totally rearrange things maybe we
get a giant planet close to the sun
or maybe we don't get a giant planet
planted anywhere near the sun and
there's really big ones out far away and
we only have little planets close to the
sun or have
six of them or ten of them instead of
eight or nine
um all of that would be different if
jupiter didn't form
[Applause]
and on top of that well if you say okay
suppose
jupiter formed we got all the planets in
the right place but
now i'm gonna just reach in and pop
jupiter out of the picture
and say what happens then you get a
totally different kind of answer
right the other planets don't get
perturbed that much anymore but anything
that's falling into the inner solar
system like comets and asteroids
mostly really small rocks maybe you
wouldn't call them asteroids
meteors things like that without jupiter
there
they don't get perturbed the same way
their orbits are very different
mars isn't big enough to do much of
anything so then you worry about well we
get hit by comets more often
or uh if you pluck jupiter out of the
picture
after everything formed but before
everything had settled down
then you get a different answer maybe
the amount of water on the earth might
be different
because jupiter probably influenced that
so
any step along in the process if you
don't have jupiter
you get a different picture but what
picture you get depends on when you took
jupiter away
it's funny because these days you know
more people are talking about how
interconnected things are here how we
have to be reminded that
even though there's seemingly a lot of
distance between us
and the other side of the world and in
fact everything has this sort of
butterfly effect if you will and affects
everything else so it's it's it's
interesting to see that that's the case
obviously the further we zoom out into
the solar system
as well you mentioned uh smaller rocks
uh and uh these days
of course the moons around jupiter i
think
especially in the sort of astronomical
circles
uh are getting as much attention maybe
even as jupiter uh
especially europa ganymede etc what has
juno been able to sort of glean more
about
uh jupiter's moons
okay so first i should say our most
important job so far
about europa has been to stay the heck
away from it
and that's because people are very
excited about
the fact that europa appears to have a
liquid water ocean
underneath its icy surf and maybe
find life in that ocean so picture 20
30 40 50 years from now you finally
built a system that can do it and you
fly to europa and you land on the ice
and you dig down beneath the ice and we
don't know whether that's a few feet or
a few hundred miles
but you dig through the ice you get into
the water you sample the water
you find life and then you have to say
but i don't know if that came from
europa or contamination for when juno
hit it 50 years ago
that would be a problem so because we're
there to study jupiter
we have to be very and we didn't go
through all the steps you do for say a
mars mission to make it as clean as
possible and have no
bacteria on it or anything like that
nothing that could survive
we have to show we're not going to
contaminate europa and what we did at
the beginning is we said all right well
we're there to study
the main planet not europa we'll just
stay the heck away from
however we're coming near the end of our
prime
mission we're writing actually sending
it in today i think
an extended mission proposal to nasa to
ask to
keep giving us money to continue because
the spacecraft's doing well and we have
lots of great new science we can do and
part of that proposal which of course
nasa will have to decide if they have
the money
part of that proposal is to study europa
because we think with our radio
receivers
that we use to look at the atmosphere we
can look at europa and tell you
something about maybe how thick the ice
is and whether there's water near the
surface
we have other instruments that if we're
lucky maybe we'll see a
plume and be able to tell something
about whether europa has geysers or not
sticking out into space
we can look at all the other satellites
and i would not think of that as
assuming it gets funded as a um like
prime mission that studies the
satellites because that's not what we
were there for and we're not
geared to do everything you want to do
to study europa
but it's a great advanced scout mission
for
nasa's mission europa clipper or the
european mission jews
that want to go to jupiter and study
those moons and learn a lot more
we can learn a little bit that might
help them refine where they do their
measurements and what they do
we can measure some things that they
weren't designed to measure because
they're focused on
on stuff that's more europa specific and
we have instruments that we're really
focused on jupiter
so we measure slightly different things
there's lots of great stuff we can do
if we get if nasa decides that they want
to fund our extended mission or has the
money to fund the extended mission
and wow if it includes breaking news
here on what if
yes yeah yeah to say that this is the
golden age of space exploration would
be an understatement we talked about the
juno mission nasa launched a probe to
mars earlier this year
we got the announcement last week and we
had a guest on talking about the
possibility of phosphine on venus and
what that might spur
in terms of further exploration what is
it like to be
working at nasa these days i gotta say
it's really fun
i mean i i've been working for nasa one
way or the other for about
30 years and um
it's always been fun because we're
exploring
we're trying to figure out things where
nobody knows the answer
um but right now we're getting close to
some really important answers
we're learning you know it's it's in my
lifetime in my career as a scientist
is you know at the beginning of my
career nobody had discovered any planets
around any other star besides our own
now it's practically practically root
tea you know they found another planet
around some other star
and it's only interesting if it's a
special case if it's
more earth-like or it's really close to
its star or really far from its star
or things like that we're getting
distributions of that we're learning how
many planets there are typically in is
our own
system we're learning about different
ways to look for life within our own
solar system
and we're getting further along doing it
our robots have gotten
so good that we can launch robotic
spacecraft and do these exploration
things that you know when i was growing
up i thought only
you know you'd have to have people there
to do and of course it's
way easier to send a robot than it is to
send a person
mostly because the robot doesn't care if
you bring give it a ride home
so all of that it's it's really a great
time to be doing
space exploration yeah and i mean with
the way the world is these days
i i know peter and i have experienced
this before that
when we get to talk to people like
yourself that you know help us zoom out
and remind us that the world isn't our
little naval gazing day-to-day that
there's just
obviously so much beyond this planet so
much to look forward to and even so much
to be optimistic about
the future versus all the dystopian
sci-fi and post-apocalyptic stuff i
think we see a lot
it's easy to forget that so this is
great can you stick around
and talk you mentioned some of those
exoplanets and and kind of future nasa
missions can you stick around for a bit
sure so we we are going to take a break
with uh dr levin right now
and he will be part of the extended
audio podcast
which you can find i guess if you're
watching youtube is the link is
where people listen if you're watching
this on youtube right now you want to
click on the link and you'll get the
extended audio version of the podcast
and we can hear the rest of the
conversation with dr levin
um but if that's all the time you have
for us today then uh
well that's fine too you can you're
gonna stick around because we're still
gonna do a little video chat
after this um and then we'll check in on
part two later
yeah so yeah peter and i'll sort of sum
up our our our takeaways from the first
half where can people you mentioned the
website for the
for the footage uh from the juno mission
where can people find that again
and uh where can people follow your work
so um the easiest thing for people to
remember is if you
go to nasa's website and search for juno
you'll find all
all this stuff with links to everything
but the main juno website is a site
called mission juno
so it's missionjuno.swri.edu
and if you just google mission juno
you'll find it or if you do a web search
for
junocam you'll find us um it's pretty
easy
just so long as you've got nasa or
jupiter or something in there to keep
from
getting confused with all the other
junos out there like the juno awards up
here
google will get you there basically
which honor the best of canadian music
you don't want that's an entirely
different junior you might want to say
yes dr levin will you want that site too
it's pretty interesting i think alanis
morissette won a juno back in the day as
as alanis but that's a story for another
whatever okay dr levin sit tight we'll
be back with you in a sec
and uh peter and i'll be back to sort of
sum up our takeaways from our
conversation with dr levin about the
juno mission
and what if jupiter never existed
cool so i guess like dr levin and
and the people at the jet propulsion
laboratory with nasa
uh they learned stuff we learned stuff
they learned that
some of the things that they had assumed
or known about jupiter turned out
not to be true or or or were at least
more than they had expected of course
because they got to finally
actually look at it from quality
pictures quality pictures
so they got to go beneath the gas
surface and see what's happening down
there
had some assumptions about it but in
fact were i think
happily proven wrong i like when
nasa does some things like that and we
find out about it and we can bring it to
the viewers
it's almost that fast i mean well i mean
in this particular case you're having
some real-time
learning going on because again he's
giving us the sort of the backstory as
to what they learned at the time and
then we're learning that and to your
point then people listening or watching
or learning
i mean i i learned also that we have
this sort of big brother big sister
relationship with jupiter on earth right
i mean
it's been essentially shielding us
protecting us
for all this time and i'd never honestly
before
i know it sounds stupid maybe but i'd
never thought that
you know all that space debris and
asteroids coming in this direction
would have naturally potentially hit us
if we weren't kind of protected from
that
side you know what i thought was
interesting was that if
jupiter he gave us an idea of how the
universe was formed
jupiter obviously was or not obviously
we learned today or i learned today
it was the second object in the solar
system
and if it hadn't been there or if it
wasn't there
it there's a possibility earth wouldn't
be here either yeah so it's not a small
relationship we have with jupiter and
what if jupiter never existed as it
turns out again as we sort of put it out
there if jupiter never existed
there's the possibility that earth never
existed but
he also added a bit of a sort of a
caveat to that that
whoever else would have been there they
might have gotten let's say the leftover
mass
so maybe in a different scenario earth
would have been the size of jupiter
and instead of having seven billion
people here we'd have 700 billion people
here
or maybe it wouldn't have uh stayed in
the habitable zone or maybe it would
have gotten too big and it wouldn't have
been enough water on it to sustain life
there would have been a whole
host of other reasons why maybe life
didn't exist it never came to be on
earth you know what it sounds like to me
peter
sounds like a story for another what if
well uh if you want to hear more of our
conversation with
nasa's steve levin and you're watching
the video podcast
on youtube well what you're going to do
is click on the link
below and it will take you to the
extended audio version
now some of you are listening already on
the audio podcast
there's no link for you don't look for
anything just
stay tuned yeah so join us on the other
side we'll talk more about life on other
planets and
uh and uh space exploration and a whole
bunch of other cool stuff europa
um and if that's all the time you have
for us today well thanks for watching
you can join us
next week when we talk about the
mysteries of the octopus
with the director of the film my octopus
teacher
you won't see an octopus in the same
light ever again no i mean they're
fascinating that's why that movie has
blown
up on netflix my octopus teacher and
it'll be really cool to get some insight
what if has done a couple of octopus or
pie
videos uh but uh this is gonna be a
really cool conversation
right that's next week on what if
[Music]
discussed